so I hear you're recording a new
Christmas cover that's really exciting
okay so we're just gonna practice some
phrasing okay
um so repeat after me
I'll Be Home for Christmas
all right you trapped
I'll Be Home for Christmas Camila
Cabello proves there's no bah humbug
Spirit over the way she once pronounced
Christmas
I'll Be Home for Christmas
and got dragged for it
in fact Camila's got the perfect
response oh my God here's a little
refresher last year the singer performed
her rendition of I'll Be Home for
Christmas for the PBS holiday special at
the White House
[Music]
[Music]
at the time Camila tweeted that it was
an incredible honor to perform at the
nation's capital before wishing her fans
a wonderful holiday
fast forward a year later and people are
getting into the holiday spirit by
re-watching Camila's performance there's
just one little thing they're really
honing in on the way she sings the word
Christmas
it didn't take long for social media
users to find clips of Camila singing
that same song at other events like
Michael Buble's Christmas in the City
and turns out her pronunciation of
Christmas at the White House wasn't just
a one-off
be home for Christmas
so on Monday Camila entered the chat and
poked fun at herself on Tick Tock so I
hear you're recording a new Christmas
cover that's really exciting okay so
we're just gonna practice some phrasing
okay
um so repeat after me
I'll Be Home for Christmas
all right you trapped
I'll Be Home for Christmas try again
home for Christmas home for Christmas
kind of like you would
um
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas the bomb
bomb singer captioned the clip quote me
before recording my version of I'll Be
Home for Christmas
yeah notice that spelling of Christmas
with a Q Christmas quiz once
Christmas
it's gonna be great
but Christmas isn't the only word Camila
seems to struggle a bit with in fact
when E.T caught up with the singer and
her fellow coaches on The Voice back in
September she teased that sometimes she
even says her own name wrong even she
does this mispronounces her own name and
you hear it over and oh John says it
wrong Gwen said you say it incorrect
said correctly every time yeah I've said
it my name is kamila
Cabello yeah yeah
Camelot Camelot yeah
okay
Camelot was my favorite well one thing's
for sure Camilla knows how to take a
joke Christmas
and she's having a blast on her debut
season of the hit singing competition
show where they all do a lot of laughing
how's the new gig it's so fun I have so
much fun with these guys I get excited
and giddy when I see you guys it's like
going to school and seeing your funny
friends clowns
foreign